where's my aunt
okay what do you want to pick that back
up at
what you think of the warner brothers
bro
uh
i feel like the wonder brothers panel
was synonymous with everything wrong
with warner brothers um
they literally just told it's it's
let's juxtapose
warner brothers gave us a really cool
intro with the rock where he comes
levitating out of the out of the stage
like jesus
hovers there for a little while and is
like
i'm gonna change everything the
hierarchy of power
in the dc universe
is about to change
sega the hierarchy of power
in the dc universe is about to change
what's that the hierarchy of power in
the dc universe is about to change sega
the hierarchy of power in the dc
universe
is about to change what did you say now
i think one part of that is just the
rock being the rock
right and just being like i'm introduced
like i'm playing a new character who's
introduced and black adam is comparable
to superman in power right i mean he's
very very capable and a fight with them
depending on who's writing it could have
a believable draw who would win in a
fight black adam or superman
[Laughter]
well look you know that's a great
question luke don't threaten me with a
good time because i'm going to answer
that
well
i will say as you guys know because
we're all in deep with this mythology
and it's been the age-old question of
who would win in a fight between black
adam and superman uh pound for pound
they're pretty close
um
i i guess it probably all depends on
who's playing superman i will just say
that
um
we got that we got to see some stuff
from shazam
[Music]
copyright um
and like that was it they didn't really
have anything meaningful what i think
the warner brothers panel illustrated is
they have no plans they don't know what
they're gonna do they have no direction
right like literally nothing's planned
out these guys are flying by the seat of
their pants you know and and it felt
like it um whereas like hey guys here's
some stuff from projects that you
already know about uh i don't think they
know what comes next and i think the
weather brother warner brothers panel
illustrated they don't know what comes
next
um it's
it was it was not terrible but there was
there's a reason no one's talking about
it you know there's a reason no one like
everybody's just like the rock looked
awesome as black adam and i can't wait
to see the movie
so what this means is
every single one of you
all of you all 6 000 of you will be the
first to see black adam on an imax
screen my gift to you
[Music]
and honestly the warner brothers panel
was just disappointing it was just not
it was not what i expected like i
expected more you know i expected like
hey guys here's what everything looks
like after flashpoint you know here's
where we're going like here's how here's
i expected something akin to what marvel
did and i felt like marvel
just destroyed
warner
have a little bit of time brothers
and there are a couple of ensembles we
haven't mentioned yet and i wonder
if you guys wouldn't mind looking ahead
a little bit with me to phase six
[Applause]
confirming
fantastic four
[Applause]
and i feel like that's because warner
brothers let it happen
by god was that he's kind of positioned
himself to be a
anti-hero tony stark iron man figure
he's very much trying to just move his
way into being that figure for dc films
and if that it is if it does pan out
like that do you think he's the perfect
fit for it
or using black adam as a character is
could potentially be the iron man of the
movie see here's the thing about black
adam man is
when it comes to black adam there is
he's a great character that has so
little exposure
in the comics
um he's had some great moments but
there's never really been an instance
where black adam has been positioned in
the same capacity as batman or superman
or or any of those guys
so i don't readily look at black adam
and see him as what could potentially be
the face
of the dc
cinematic universe going forward having
said that if they do i would love that
um
but i think the rock's also overselling
it um because i don't
i mean i don't see the rock doing this
for
15 years he's 50 years old
you know and sure he's in great shape
but that 50 year old dwayne johnson
physique is not going to be there when
he's 65.
and you got to keep in mind that like
tony stark give or take played iron man
for about a decade you know maybe a
little bit longer than that if you you
know add some of the you know maybe
potential appearances or you know kind
of fudge the lines a little bit
but uh you know is dwayne johnson going
to be the rock in 10 years
i don't know uh and it's not even really
it's it's partially because of the rock
right it's partly partially because of
what dwayne johnson is capable of doing
physically in 10 years
i mean i think it's because
warner brothers
their dc cinematic universe is literally
a laboring beast gasping for breath i
don't know it's going to even be a thing
in 10 years
uh
yeah i don't even know if it's gonna i
don't know if what the rock what the
rock hopes will happen will even come to
fruition in ten years but do i think
that the rocks black adam could be the
linchpin do i think that warner brothers
could build a cinematic universe around
an anti-hero
like the rock i think i think that's a
big thing that was focused on in in jeff
john's um
shazam in the seven seven magic lands at
the end of that story black adam becomes
a good guy and he joins the shazam
family um so i don't know if he'll join
the shazam family and you know in this i
mean they are going to meet their powers
are basically identical it'd be
ridiculous to have them as two
characters and never meet right it'd be
like when steve austin when goldberg
went to wwe you know and him and steve
austin never wrestled right like the
greatest match that never happened um
you know i you're definitely gonna see
the rock and you're definitely gonna see
uh zachary levi shazam meet and most
likely come to blows you know some kind
of misunderstanding same thing with
superman but i think they're positioning
him to become a good guy
and that in doing so
will he become the face of the mcu
i'm sorry of a warner brothers dc
cinematic universe no
at least not unless henry cavill leaves
as superman
as long as henry cavill's there he's
gonna be the face
whether dwayne johnson wants him to or
not because it's not up to dwayne
johnson it's up to the fan base fan base
decides who the face of any superhero
movie franchise is
we as the fans decided it was tony stark
because we loved tony stark if at any
point over the course of the mcu tony
stark started losing popularity they
would have shifted his ass out and they
would replace him with somebody else
captain america or whatever they
wouldn't have forced it uh one of others
might but
you know people love henry cavill i mean
one of the big talking points coming out
like just listening to people at hall h
one of the big talking points coming out
is yeah everything was cool i really
wish we'd gotten to see henry cavill
like that was a big thing that people
were saying so henry cavill is still
very very popular um
so do i think that dwayne johnson will
become the face of the dc cinematic
universe
if henry cavill's not coming back as
superman if henry cavill is coming back
as superman
no
it won't happen